ladies and gentlemen welcome to the FTTH
conference 2017 the theme of this year
is together building a brighter future
what do you mean by a brighter future
I'm talking about building a gigabit
society gigabit do you mean the Internet
it is not just about Internet
connectivity
it's about laying the foundations for
Europe's children to be able to compete
on a level playing field with their
global peers it's about removing the
barriers to digital innovation so
Europe's can be positioned at the
forefront of the world's digital
societies it's about ensuring that all
citizens are equally connected to the
gigabit society whether they live in
urban or rural areas and whatever their
backgrounds are you sure you really need
fiber for this yes because fiber goes
well beyond internet access it is an
enabler for many innovative services and
it is future proof we need to ensure
that Europe has the necessary
infrastructure to permit its industries
to take leadership positions in the
emerging arenas of 5g the Internet of
Things autonomous vehicles smart grid
and more this infrastructure is needed
to kick-start Europe's economy Wow
I get it but is this really that urgent
yes it is really urgent it is key to
build this future proof infrastructure
now and connect everyone everything
everywhere now together let's get to
work and build this gigabit society
let's build a brighter future we count
on you to participate and share your
thoughts about building a gigabit
society
you